yeah so I'm happy to be here for the
secret life of pons and the title you
know it seems a little silly but one
thing is I do believe that different
players have different relationships to
their pawns like an intuitive thing some
people think they're about that they
want to promote and my pawns usually
aren't that ambitious my pawns they are
about controlling things and we're gonna
talk a little bit about that today the
game we're going to talk about we could
have talked about a lot of different
games but I'm really interested of
course in the match coming up with Fabi
and Cara Juana so I want to use one of
their games that they played that I
think is going to be a little bit
typical for the struggle that's gonna
happen
starting on the 9th so let's dive into
it and let me show you how this game
started this is from the Olympiad in
2014 and Carlsen does something that
we're gonna be at one of my big
questions for the match gum coming
forward is will he play things like this
and what I mean by that is with us
offbeat kind of line like this the main
move that Bobby would have been prepared
for is Queen a5 right and you guys have
probably seen that move at some point in
your chest career in Queen d8 you might
have seen to but it's just kind of like
not the thing that you're gonna study or
anything like that and so what's gonna
happen here is black is gonna be down a
little bit of time and he's gonna be
down a little bit in space but he's
still gonna have a very solid position
and favi is gonna have to work very hard
to beat him especially with space we're
gonna talk a little bit more about space
a little later all right let's get into
this and I'll show you the the intended
structure that Carlson has for himself
here
Knight of six Knight f3 Bishop g4 H 3
and now Carlsen just snips it and this
will help us understand what black wants
okay so this is a good point to start
thinking about the dynamics in the
position and while I'm talking maybe
just think about what you would do is
white because Fabi plays a move here
which is very beautiful and I would have
never inflate it as the kind of move
that wouldn't have crossed my mind but
so let me just talk a little bit about
the basics of the pawn structure and
what we see happening the first thing I
think is really important to see is that
this pawn I have to learn how to
properly do this here oh I didn't want
to do that this pawn here is dominating
the knight on c3
and what I see a lot of I wouldn't even
say beginning level players but even
2200 level players and above a lot of
times they won't realize how bad the
night is on c3 it looks like a develop
piece they're accustomed to kind of
thinking it as a develop East but it's
truly dominated by the pawn on c6 ok the
next thing we should say is that what
black has given up in addition to some
time and space is he's given up as light
square Bishop and so that means that
this guy oh hi didn't mean to do that
this guy here is the potential champion
of White's position so you can imagine
if the position opens all the lights
pores will be dominated by that one
Bishop so notice that the first thing
that Magnus did is the pawn on c6 is a 1
on a light square so it's meant to block
the light square bishop his next move is
going to be pawn to e6 so that's going
to be like a wall for the light square
bishop and you can see once once that
structure happens that black will be in
crack
we solid and he'll have a good Bishop on
FA fact all of his pieces will be more
or less good Bishop c4 now notice the
pawn on d4 is hanging right okay d5 is
interesting also upon sacrifice right
okay it's funny you know when you ask
people what if the about us in a certain
position if there's some nice move
people almost always suggest the
sacrifice everything is gonna be a
sacrifice no so let's just say the
natural move here that I think many
people would do is Bishop III and it's
not the most terrible move but watch
what Fabi does because it's really
beautiful he says alright this knight on
c3 isn't working and I'm going to use
him to guard the pawn on d4
it's I think it's still flexible where
he's gonna go it's you know it's this
funny thing of course let's just say why
would know and think of this because
you're blocking the bishop on f1 and in
summary and just intuitively most people
feel like their Knight is more powerful
on c3 than e2 because I need to is just
touching six squares and on c3 it's
touching eight so the knight is going to
eat you and then we're going to see
later it has the dream of being useful
on g3 okay so let's look at how this
goes 92 the first really nice move by
Fabi c6 and now g4 okay so let's talk
about it now the plan is becoming a
little clearer we can put the bishop on
g2 and later we want to make the knight
on f6 poor by playing a move like g5
gaining some space and this is the other
thing that I think is critical for the
match coming up where Carlson is willing
to play positions where he's a little
bit worse like he is here but he saw it
and in order to beat Magnus in a
position like this you are going to have
to really strangle his pieces for lots
of moves lots and lots of moves and if
you slip then that's it right so I
really like fabi's play so far let's
keep on going here
Queen d5 Bishop g2
97 Queen g3
Quincy for Queen b3
takes takes all right I went through
that kind of quickly but it was a
natural development from what we had
before well does anybody have a sense
actually I'll tell you what let me play
Magnus's move first cuz it's very
natural we should be six what does it
want to have a sense of what they think
is happening in this position see you
like c4 right now uh-huh okay what I
want you guys to see is that at whatever
level you're at when you get to a
position like this what you should be
thinking about doing is making your
opponent's pieces bad and yours better
way that's all it is that's all they're
doing here
and the only reason I think Magnus has a
chat or excuse me Fabi has a chance at
being a little better here is because
some of his white black's pieces are
funny-looking okay let's take a look at
what Fabi plays it's a very committal
move see for now in my own secret life
of pawns this move makes me very nervous
okay because what now is permanently
happening is that this pawn is always
going to be weak there's no way for my
pawn on c4 to go back to c3 and it
really is in a lot of ways now like an
isolated pawn it's a completely
different pawn structure than if white
plays pawn c3 right on pawn c3 I'm going
to be able to just always have that guy
defended and so it's a sacrifice it's
really a long-term sacrifice from white
and the idea is I guess simply to stop
the knight this guy from coming to d5
right so the idea is simple we are
taking squares away from this pieces in
particular his Knight so think about the
night on d7 it's dominated by the pawn
on D
and the knight on f6 were working at
some point to play g5 okay now one thing
I'll say is that you get this structure
by the way a lot of times in a Carl Kahn
maybe I'll just show that quickly c6 d 4
D 5 it's the same structure right and in
the karo con as well a lot of times you
want to just trade off your light square
bishop and then zero in on that D pawn
okay so when we come back here there are
risks involved now for white the game
has become riskier with c4 it's an
ambitious move okay let's do a couple
more moves a six Bishop e3 by the way a6
excuse me I didn't mean to castle a 6
because the rook on a1 is hitting a 7
and black decides the castle this way
and we castle now
now I will say that having played
positions like this it's very hard and
takes a lot of energy it feels like oh
man it feels like a lot of energy when
you're playing these especially a strong
opponent and they're so solid like this
rook he8 and now Knight g3 and at this
point I think White has to be really
happy though even though it's a hard
road ahead very happy about the position
and we are looking in my mind we're
looking to play g5 fairly soon let's
take a look at how this goes let me just
say this a lot of players would be
tempted as black to play moves like c5
excuse me or b5 right it just feel
because it feels like you're liberating
your position or something like that but
remember that's like the main goal for
white is to get you to make one of those
moves because this man really wants
those light squares the pawns on e6 and
c6 are the barrier for that Bishop but
if that bishop ever got opened then
watch out it's a real problem right so
Magnus very patient in this position and
one of the things that you know black
needs to understand if he's going to
play this structure that you can play
with the pieces but you can't really
play with the pawns
okay now Knight f8
this position
I've studied quite a bit just looking at
on my own and I will say I know for a
fact that if I was playing white I would
now play g5 without thinking at all
about it and mag and Fabi doesn't play
g5 so it's kind of an interesting
question like well why didn't he do it
yeah - FA I don't think so no notice
actually this is a good point actually
to think about Magnus's position given
that you're not going to play e5 or c5
the night on d7 is pretty miserable so
he needs to do something and I think the
dream that Magnus has here and we're
gonna actually see it is at some point
the night might come to g6 right f4 from
white here g6 f4 that's right yeah so I
spent a lot of time on this and I think
this is an interesting thing because
from this point on it's kind of like
Magnus kind of gets inside Bobby's head
here so imagine like this position we're
going to see Carlson now out plays Fabi
and this is the kind of thing that
worries me for the World Championship
this kind of position because I too
would want to win this position to push
but it's really hard to notice just how
solid the black position is I think this
is what I think that the reason he
didn't play g5 was that he was concerned
about giving up this square in
particular that the night would come
here and then go through isse Evan and
then land on f5
now I think it's still debatable how big
of a deal it is and I would still do it
yeah what eff initely still do it if I
was black but you know let's say for
example h4 Knight d7 h5 and I think
black is gonna play this ugly-looking
move g6 and the idea is okay ninety-four
looks really good that once black right
once this is the thing I think Fabi is
kind of afraid of once the night lands
on the f5 you're never gonna get it out
and this pawn for example if you take on
d6 right you take on d6 if that pawn
will permanently be a worry for you you
will and that's the point of this
Scandinavian structure you're just
aiming for some kind of end game where
the pawn is the thing that you're gonna
get your counter play from and sometimes
win the game so I still think he should
have played g5 but yeah this I think is
why he didn't do it so you see with
pawns right they are there to control
your opponent's pieces and a metaphor
that I like quite a bit is to imagine
like a person's life their career right
and when you think about a career it's
like some situations in life are going
to suit your skillset and others are not
right and the same thing with the pawn
structures you go through these
different pawn structures and sometimes
it's good for a piece and sometimes it's
not so a very good practical rule that I
tell everybody is anytime there's a
change in pawn structure that's when you
should re-evaluate who you think are the
good pieces and the bad pieces because
their roles a lot of times change just
instantly with the pawned change and
what the psychological trick is like if
you've been thinking that a certain
piece has been Tara
for a long time or good for a long time
that you don't know reevaluate what's
going on once that pawn structure change
happens okay so here we go with fabi's
interesting plan Bishop f3 and what is
the point
white wants white wants to control g4 we
don't want to play g5 so we don't give
him the f5 Square and by doing so by
controlling g4 we are now intending to
play h4 h5 to hopefully dominate the
night on f8 right so we're still playing
for the domination of the Knights but
now we're moving to dominate the knight
on FA okay so here we go
Knight G 6 h4 and now we're gonna get a
pawn structure change
and the night 97 right he's boldly
saying well if you ever play g5 I'm
ready to go ready to come at you over
there you do it okay in this position I
would still play g5 if I was Bobby but
Bobby does come up with an amazing and
interesting plan try to put yourself in
his shoes for a second you have a choice
between g5 which like your average GM
like me would play or think about this
others thought the night on g3 really
wants glory right so just put yourself
in fabi's shoes for a second and imagine
the following plan E 4 E 5 you get ePHI
for free because you tap the knight
right and then you play Knight e4 and
then on after 94 you go into d6 looks
really strong right looks really strong
and this is a funny thing because this
is how Magnus will get you that's a
really interesting moment here so the
pawn structure first of all it's totally
changed after this Bishop takes III
thing right and what I want you guys to
pay attention to is that the drawback of
that plan of efore is magnus immediately
plays h6 and now the pawns are fixed the
white pawns are fixed on these light
squares now why is that a big deal
because the bishop wants his pawns to be
on dark squares so for two reasons one
so that the bishop can move around and
is not blocked by his own pawns and also
so that the pawns on the dark squares
control the dark squares and he controls
the lights course it's like bricks and
mortar you need both you can't just have
one okay so here we go though he
five-night h7
94 so one way of thinking about it's
like Fabi has sacrificed this square on
g5 for the ability to put the knight on
d6 right
another important thing I think about
this is that Robbie is still also
claiming that the knight on e7 is bad
and that's kind of we're gonna see the
crux of the position because if black
can then make that piece reasonable then
he might really be able to use these
pawn weaknesses that White's created
remember this guy's a disaster now right
long-term
this guy's weak and black structure
continues to be incredibly solid notice
that the pawn on f7 is going to be
guarded nicely by the knight on d5 right
so it's a funny thing when do we go back
to position like this first of all I
can't claim I would even see that plan a
v4 u5 94-96 but if I saw it what would
my heart start racing and I thought I'd
have something special probably yeah
that looks cool that's really cool so
yeah this is the level of subtlety that
is gonna be happening in the match where
a lot of times you get something and
then it's not the Christmas present you
thought you were gonna open right okay
so here we go
rook f8 we get our beautiful night check
King c7
so right now when we started looking at
it the night he's not doing as much as
we might have hoped them to do right
it's unclear how we're gonna get
something effective happening
I liked your suggestion of b4 b5 if we
could arrange something like that then
at least you know the bishop could help
the night because as it is he's just all
on his own over there he's a very
beautiful piece no one's denying right
but he's all on his own there on d6 okay
so here we go
Bishop g2 we have to get out of the way
of the night that's coming to g5 anyway
Knight g5 rook h f1 f6 all right so now
the first problem is raising its head
namely if you allow us to take on e5
which seems hard to avoid
then we're gonna black is going to have
a weakness on e5 to talk to right notice
also the bishop on g2 it's a long-term
plan that began from the opening the
bishop on g2 is running up against a
wall here right okay so white improved
his king Magnus took
and then here's a very tricky thing so
again playing with a space advantage is
very difficult because a lot of times
like here you make pong weaknesses in
order to control your opponent's pieces
and what happens is if they ever get out
they will be particularly angry pieces
because they're going to be jumping all
over the weaknesses that you created
trying to hold them in they literally
are like the caged animals that got out
right once they get out
so let's look Knights e8 now the only
way to make the knight proud is to play
c5 but now what's the problem all right
97 is interesting anything else true
what else
97 to d5 freedom has now been achieved
freedom has now been achieved and now
we're gonna see that in the next several
moves Fabi really tie it tries to squirm
it it doesn't it doesn't look good all
of a sudden so for example let's look B
495 this night is now so strong you
better take the thing right I've got the
B Foursquare to worry about I've got the
e 3 Square to worry about I've got the F
4 Square to worry about the thing is all
of a sudden he's a monster he's come in
behind all the weaknesses that you've
created okay now I think when probably
played before he had the following
intention which is at least an attempt
at counter play he takes C takes no
notice the problem right away is that
once the Bishop leaves now the knight
gets this Square on f3 right okay so b5
is the intention
takes takes king c6 Knight d6 no and
this part is not so hard right Knight f3
now fabi's a B probably is a good
defender look at its B for think for a
moment what is the problem with Knight
e5 the problem with Knight takes e5 it's
not necessarily the end of the world
kind of problem which is the thing black
would rather not face I think though
things are falling like the G for pawn
and stuff like that
right okay everything you guys are
saying about rook e1 and stuff that's
all correct but there's a first there's
a move here that Bobby wanted to do and
that's b5 and now King takes e5 as a
problem and b5 in itself is a huge bonus
for me for my position right because I
make your King go back and now I can do
all kinds of counter play things maybe
like rook e1 right yeah no I still think
black probably has the advantage here
but it's getting messy it's getting more
messy than you want it to be so very
calm move rook e8
he takes a file basically forcing Fabi
to play Brooke a1 now we take it and now
we take you five no counterplay yeah and
I like that but the poor knight on d6
like we're gonna play b6 soon he's gonna
have a problem he's gonna be totally
undermined what's that
rookie one let's try it out I think
rookie one isn't bad there's a number of
moves this one's kind of annoying right
because if rookie six and 94
that's a good question though I mean
that you can see that I'm sure Magnus
had saw that in advance so he played
rook a seven rook b8 again it's just
like a very calm move which is going to
deny the counter play there's really not
much that white can do yeah so white
went back to guard against things like
Knight f3
and now b6 okay seven takes check takes
let's undermine again right what a
bummer I think Bobby is truly flailing
at this point rook a 786 yeah I think
this actually happened even though it's
pretty gross g5 there's nothing really
happening right D 495 King d5 Knight d7
d3 if you go to d2 or something I'm
gonna check with the rooks he goes king
c1 and after takes takes guinea for
Magnus isn't even bothering with a g5
pawn he just knows that this is a
winning position right because I'm gonna
play things like King III coming soon
okay yeah so there it is the secret life
points let me just review a couple
positions that I thought were kind of
critical right for one you can see like
first of all I think Bobby played a
number of moves here that I really like
I love the move 92 very deep move and
you know sometimes maybe like all of you
you despair at some point about chess
like chess might seem unfair and you
know the kids are beating you down and
whatever but moves like this are like
what keep bringing me back to the game
honestly because it's a beautiful thing
there's always ways to find ideas and
one cool thing about playing stronger
players I'll say in my own
experiences you know getting hit with a
move like 92 and just having to figure
it out in your own head it's really
difficult yeah and then you know we
rolled into this pawn structure and it's
really fascinating because you can see
what White's
objectives are it almost you know anyone
can see it but it's so hard to achieve
right and there's so much resilience in
the black position here this move well I
thought that was like that was the shot
you know now we're coming for you magnet
there we go one thing actually I'll say
I really admire about Fabi as the kid
isn't he's not afraid you know oh and c4
very committal it's a first actually
let's call it the first incredibly
committal pawn move right and and II 45
is going to be the next one hey six then
we got castles castles simple this is
very useful for anyone playing any kind
of structure like this do not move your
pawns especially the pawns on c6 and e6
right don't let the Bishop out alright
93 9f8 Bishop f3 again I would have
played g5 and let's look again at how
this goes 9 g 6h for Bishop f4 h5 Bishop
e3 Fe 397 right so while you're watching
we come in and on the night this is the
kind of thing that we're gonna get we're
gonna get I think I would surprise me if
we didn't get a lot of end games I think
we are gonna get a lot of end games like
this and it's gonna be moments like this
where when we look at it I think we have
to say that White's a little bit better
you know nothing outrageous but I think
White's a little bit better but once you
see that plan of sticking the knight on
d6 it looks great
oh it looks beautiful to me you know
that looks like a good plan and so
that's one of the things you know we're
gonna be watching for during that during
the our broadcasts and stuff here and
all around the world right okay
any questions
[Music]